New suit?
Yeah.
Real cool.
You clearly don't mean
that.
Oh, black cape.
I mean,
where do you get these
super ideas?
Okay,
I didn't
steal this from you.
If that's
what you're implying.
Why stop there?
Why not drive
my car,
sleep in my mansion,
get tipsy,
and tongue, kiss
my butler.
You just.
I know what I said.
I have things to do.
Let me just
cut to the quick, okay?
Okay.
No good company
has two CEO’s
I think
we need to crystallize
the leadership
of the Justice League.
Okay.
The quickest way to do that
is to can your ass.
Can my ass.
Like sardines,
bitch.
Here's the thing, Bruce.
If someone
should step down.
It should be you.
You're dressed like a bat.
I am a bat.
No you’re not.
You’re not a bat.
You're a scared little boy
playing dress up
distracting
the grown ups
with actual powers
who are trying to deal
with actual problems.
I help.
Really? Yes.
Remember when we fought
those parademons?
They were tough.
I totally took down
one of them.
Oh, please.
The only reason
you knocked out
that parademon was
because I held it down
like a dad
who takes a few cracks
at a pinata
so his son can hit it
once.
Knock out the candy
and feel like a big boy.
That's why Alfred always
pre-hits the pinata?
You're useless.
Eat sh*t.
F*ckwad
Good come back.
Hope starts with an H.
You step on my best
stuff last time.
It's time you packed up
your stuff and left.
Bruce.
Okay.
Hold on. Umm.
Let's walk this back
instead of you
being fired or me
being fired.
How about
co-leaders?
Musk one
and Musk two.
You can own Twitter.
I'll make battery cars.
You sure?
Because it felt like
you brought me in
here to fire me.
Noo, come on.
You don't know me
by now.
I was joshin’
let’s commemorate
our new partnership.
And Will,
we'll just
have ourselves
a little toast.
What do you say?
Happy to hear it.
Okay.
Cheers.
These wouldn't
be kryptonite
cubes, would they?
Kal.
Look, I know
you have trust issues.
Your parents put you in
like a
yeast infection pill
and sent you
to our planet.
But you can trust me.
This is not kryptonite.
This is.
This is green tea
from Asia.
From Asia.
green tea
from Asia.
Where in Asia?
Asia. Minor.
Mean, if it's
so good, you
drink first.
I would.
And you're from
Krypton,
so you don't know this.
But the custom
is that the guest drinks
the green tea from Asia
first.
Drink first.
So you drink
first, please.
You drink first.
Okay.
All right.
You know,
I am a little
thirsty, so
here I go.
Drinking the normal tea.
I don't
want to be offensive,
but it's not good to my palette.
Yeah, you're
fired, Bruce.
Hold, on.
Look, look, you.
You win.
You're the boss.
But before I go,
I was wondering
if you could help me
with one small thing.
You're so strong.
Could you help me open
this innocent jar of pickles?
What kind of pickels are those?
I'd say Jewish.
They look like
kryptonite.
Oh, no, no, no.
Those.
These are.
These are
these are kryptonot
brand pickles.
You know, when you’re trying to lie, it's
best not to call it
basically the
exact same word.
Note taken.
But uh, one last thing.
Quick question,
you want to
put your hand
in this Shrek puppet?
It will not
wither you
like an old man.
I'm not going to put
my hand
in the glowing green
Shrek puppet, Bruce.
Come, on!
It'll be fun.
You could be like,
Oh, I am an ogre.
I live in a swamp.
Hey, now,
ur a rock star.
Get your game on.
Get paid.
Hey now, ur rock star.
Get ya game on.
Get laid.
Batman!
Sorry.
I fell
in one of my
Shrek holes.
The last one lasted
the entire quarantine.
This is
getting beyond stupid.
You have
the rest of the day
to pack up your stuff
and leave the.
Hall of Justice.
Oh, hold this
hold this rock.
Really?
Just hold this rock?
You're not even
trying anymore.
Look at it.
It's Rocky.
Very holdable.
You could hold it.
You see me
hold the rock.
Puts an itch
in your brain.
Nothing’s gonna
scratch that itch.
Like holding da rock.
I want you to
visualize something
in your mind.
It's you.
You look down in your hand.
There’s something in it.
It's this rock.
So f**king sad.
Go play with the gadget
and your Legos.
You toddler.
What a Farquaad.